[Musique]
Notre tâche, ce faisant, ce sont les donateurs
modifier génétiquement des porcs de cette façon
que vos organes après le
la transplantation chez l'homme ne
être repoussé comment on fait on
besoin de modifications génétiques pour cela
introduire trois gènes porcins
éteindre et au moins deux
les gènes humains ajoutent que tout
s'exécute dans des cellules de porc en culture
nous cherchons ensuite ces cellules
dans lequel la modification
cru et ensuite nous utilisons cela
dix pour le transfert de base, ce qui signifie que
Le clonage après la super technique pour sortir du
cellules pour produire d'abord des embryons
et ces embryons sont alors dans le
élevage porcin receveur thierry
les transfère puis use ça
signifie qu'après 114 à 116 jours, ils viennent
génétiquement modifiés semblent alors
monde
[Musique]
si le cochon utilise ça aux USA
était un cochon cloné qui
signifie que vous l'avez génétiquement décuplé
cellules modifiées à travers le noyau
virement effectué c'est pour le
utilisation clinique de routine
pas la bonne façon parce que c'est du clonage
lui-même peut avoir des effets secondaires
qui veulent m'éviter nous le ferons
nos porcs donneurs en tout cas
créer par élevage c'est nous
seuls les animaux fondateurs le sauront
clone générer puis tous les autres
générations tout à fait normalement, pour ainsi dire
élevage créé
c'est en fait très complexe
sujet sur lequel vous êtes réellement
beaucoup
doit considérer les phases mais comme
association de protection des animaux nous pensons que oui
bien sûr éthiquement très discutable et oui
pas acceptable parce que les animaux ne sont pas considérés
magasin de pièces de rechange pour les personnes qui servent
ne devrait pas faire de différence si
animal de compagnie soi-disant clown de bétail ou
l'iris est né naturellement
sentience
lui-même pas dans quel but est sur
qui est dans le monde et a le même